hello and welcome bring to this video
playing + + from Norway ok 1 d4 often
the problem ok got a Slav now play the
Queen move for a change I play this Andy
336 you don't see that too often hmm
interesting yeah here wyd had a choice
between a more classical approach with
Bishop f4 and so on and III beach by 43
or or even if or and g3 I think I'd
rather go for the classical approach
this is Maya yeah more normal let's say
for my for my chest I don't think at all
that often if I start with D for in the
first place but we'll see depends a bit
also if he goes Bishop g7 now what what
he does yeah if for he has this be 5v5
base counter play ok I think I'll just
go for simple development
it should be six tween a for probably
okay
I'll just develop if he goes there
should be six probably queen bee three a
95 might be a move in some cases but I
have Bishop b5 so don't mind that so
much Bishop is 623 I guess
yeah it looks okay not super ammonius
why its position but you will see
anything bad happening to me
on I am not sure if I want to take and
yeah I think that's still a good
decision clarify the situation and now
castle yeah that is that at the end
really leading to a good position I'm a
threatening 95 now and then the night a
to that I just don't believe it okay I
carrick see one and I now i'm up for you
for that should be should be rather good
for wild night can come to have six then
the i like best if possible to play c4
here naughty form as c4 as a position
that this is not weakened wherever I
don't have any weakness and here I'm
actually threatening d5 check NC 5 let's
see five hmm yeah so might be able to
just take a take stuff
see 594
mmm might go Queen a3 mc5 GI it's
probably just good but a four is also
good does this makes decision difficult
okay this I didn't think about it or
what I thought I'd just take I just take
be seven and that's it
looks like too much material c6 is
hanging and I'm close to just killing
any sort of initiative with Queen 86
that he might get and there's 95 coming
out looks good rupee aid i can probably
take c6 where there's also just tween 86
the c6 porn is very weak anyway 93 i
just played the bishop of the backpack
or queen 86 also not a better bed reply
nice and yes i would move him
95cm scott seems to be good here right
just this rugby 896 it's pretty awkward
where I will be 896 that's it six is a
very annoying thread though now no moves
between d2 I can take this out if
anything else fails
black resides yeah it loses the house
yeah he had a decent position here for
sure but somehow that went went downhill
rather quickly to be honest I don't
think that night before has great him
this ultimately leads to these two
problems I'm not threatening to take
here and possibly a three or a three
immediately a computer wants to play 9
a-6 back which shows that it wasn't a
great decision and after that it already
is pretty awful how Queen takes is also
very strong threatening a 3 that wins
immediately actually empty five now I
was just thinking I didn't really think
anymore I just looked at beat eggs and
and I saw this position which is very
nice for white but it's just nice it's
not winning 23 wins the game immediately
because of this threat and a day three
this is a dual-threat the best
relatively best is this but this also
loses material interesting yeah but now
no it's good but it's not winning Queen
B 6 for example I'm happy with the
position but it's it's a grind I know
it's nice t5 is a big threat and now see
five wins yeah this is this is better
may be given by the comp but I can still
take him I it's pretty bad and here
black ass out of moose something like
this is very very decisive yeah those
green felt type of positions they are
very delicate here black often has
enough play of course against white
center but if it fails and displayed
somewhat somewhat unprofessional x face
quite
quite violent shame okay well thanks for
watching